[Music]
hello so time for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and tonight
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author christina
patterson and the deputy editor of
conservative home henry hill very good
evening to both of you we will chat in a
moment after we've looked at those front
pages starting with the observer which
combines the heatwave and the tory
leadership stories with the minister who
led the cop 26 climate summit saying
he'll resign if the new prime minister
fails to commit to strong action against
climate change
while the sunday express leads with
rishi sunak pledging to scrap a mountain
of eu red tape within 100 days if he is
elected prime minister that story also
the main item on the front of the sunday
telegraph
meanwhile the sunday people has a story
about rival candidate penny mordant's
campaign funding
the sunday times also leads with penny
mordants and leaked papers which it says
cast doubts on her claims that she has
never supported watering down the rules
on the process for gender transitioning
the mirror reports that although boris
johnson missed today's cobra meeting on
the heatwave emergency he's still
planning a party at checkers to mark the
end of his time as prime minister
and finally the star on sunday tells us
that the heat wave is likely to be
followed by a baby boom
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you can see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and we're
joined tonight by the journalist and
author christina patterson and the
deputy editor of conservative home henry
hill have a good evening to you both
hope you're keeping cool this saturday
night lots to uh discuss let's start
with the sunday times
shall we
they are saying that chaos looms as
britain faces the big 4-0 christina do
you want to kick off things tonight
yes well i mean it's funny i was um
having a coffee this morning and i sat
next to uh at the next table there were
a couple of women saying oh people
always make a fuss about the weather and
i thought uh actually 40 degrees is
really very very hot i mean that is if
if we do go up to 40 degrees and it's
looking like it that will be the hottest
day ever recorded in this country and
although you know some of us enjoy the
sunshine and the heat this is is very
serious because uh even when it has been
much less hot i think last time it
reached something like 38 degrees i
think about 1 400 people actually died
as a result in the heat and the
predictions are that
people this will be very dangerous for
help even apparently for people who are
actually uh you know pretty healthy and
certainly
older and vulnerable people will be more
at risk so it is very it's very alarming
and anyone who thinks that climate
change is a fiction really really needs
to uh you know wake up and and taste the
coffee as as these people sitting next
to me were not doing this morning
because this is i mean we are in a you
know the heatwave that is going through
europe the wildfires uh this is really
emergency stuff and it shows we
absolutely do have to take action now
yeah i mean what do you think henry
about some hospitals deciding to cancel
routine appointments and surgeries uh
also some schools deciding to close on
monday and tuesdays at nurseries as well
is that sensible or is it an
overreaction
i would absolutely not second-guess
medical professionals when they make
decisions like this i think the
important thing to remember is that in
other countries where hot weather like
this is more normal they do absolutely
adapt their working day their
infrastructure how they build their
buildings everything is adapted around
those temperatures so i think that it
would be
you know risky and unwise for because we
don't normally get temperatures like
this say oh it's just a sunny day let's
keep doing everything as normal it's
probably sensible to take precautionary
steps to try and reduce pressure on the
nhs and emergency services so that
people who are vulnerable and do need
care need them i think the bigger
question is if we're going to keep
having days like this and more of them
as years go by and summers start to get
hotter and hotter the question we need
to start asking politicians need to
start starting quite quickly is right
how do we start adapting to this you
know we're used to talking about how to
insulate homes when do we start talking
about how to get homes cool especially
places like care homes where where
elderly people are how do we
put provisions in place to make sure
that schools have go-to plans for not
letting
extended hot summers disrupt learning i
think honestly that's the debate we need
to start having once hopefully we've got
this immediate heat wave out of the way
yeah um which leads us nicely onto the
front of the observer christina um alex
sharma has given them uh an exclusive
interview what he says is quite
interesting um he's warning that he
could well quit if the new prime
minister doesn't have the right climate
credentials and decides to to dump the
net zero plan
yes well this is actually a a really
significant intervention because alex
sharma worked incredibly hard on the cop
uh
22 what's it called cop culture anyway
26. um and and i remember him talking
movingly about i think he cried at the
end of it i mean he didn't get exactly
the result he wanted um because you know
for all the reasons but he did you know
there was a certain degree of consensus
i think
almost nobody now or nobody's sane
denies that climate change is real that
human caused climate change is real and
it is an emergency and we absolutely
have to work globally in cooperation
with other countries and individually as
nations to try to avert that emergency
and honestly if you've been watching or
reading about how the potential
candidates uh with the exception really
of rishi sunak i'm not sure where uh i
don't think that tom tugan hat i'm not
sure exactly where he stands on this but
then he hasn't got a hope in hell of
becoming prime minister anyway but the
others have been sort of
out buying each other in their desire to
drop um net zero targets or at least
action and uh kemi babe notch actually
said in the debate last night that you
know it's more important the economic
crisis facing the country is more
important the economic crisis facing the
country is extremely important but
pretty much nothing is more important
than the climate emergency that the
world is facing so i mean i'm glad he's
made this intervention i hope because
these people are trying to please the
0.3 percent of the population who will
be voting in the tory party members and
unfortunately a very high proportion of
those seem to be in denial about climate
change or they don't care but the rest
of us do care and if they want to have a
future for their grandchildren they
should care so well done
yes
would you agree with that henry do you
think the the green agenda hasn't been
getting enough prominence in the in the
leadership debate and do you think it is
going to in the coming days
i think it will certainly receive more
attention camera bad knock i think went
so far as to call net zero unilateral
economic disarmament which gives you a
rough idea of the of the position of her
intervention but i think it's it's not
really accurate to describe this as
purely a problem of tory of tory
candidates pitching to a small minority
of activists who don't think climate
change is real i think actually there's
a much much bigger problem and it's
going to be a problem whether the tories
or labour are in office which is the
long-term very important work of pushing
towards net zero and combating climate
change is going to run headlong against
the short-term imperatives of a cost of
living crisis which is fueled in large
part by a crisis in global energy
markets now it's all very it's not just
a tiny minority of headbangers in the
conservative party membership who are
going to be demanding action which cuts
across the net zero agenda it's going to
be everybody who wants subsidised fuel
bills it's going to be all the boaters
who expect the government to pull out
all the stops to secure more energy and
that means at this point fossil fuels in
the long term the net zero agenda is
hugely important and i support it but
things like nuclear energy uh green and
renewable energy those have long leading
times and thanks to the war in ukraine
we now have an acute crisis which is
only going to be bridged by fossil fuels
so i think it's a clear point of tension
i hope that we see more attention put
onto it in the coming days but i think
it's important just for the sake of
actually getting to grips with the
problem to recognize the scale of the
problem this is not simply a tiny group
of headbands versus the rest of us this
is the economic interests of the
short-term economic interests of most
people versus the long-term interests of
everybody okay
let's talk about another uh topic that
the leadership hopefuls are wrestling
with gender identity it's on the front
of the sunday times
a lot of mud slinging in the sunday
papers christina uh penny more than the
front runner but quite a lot of it aimed
at her
yes well um i have to say that about the
only thing i had really registered with
penny mordant apart from the fact that
she was keen to go on tv in a swimsuit
it was her stance on
self id for trans people she had a very
clear and firm stance on this and it put
her loggerheads with quite a lot of
people who didn't share it but you know
one could argue it was brave to do that
and she was when she was equalities
minister it was pretty clear that she
was in favor of self id now that uh the
candidates are fighting each other and
in particular liz truss and penny
mordant it seems that um
some papers have been unearthed and we
haven't seen them so we can't comment on
the accuracy or inaccuracy of this claim
that um let's just say don't quite
support her assertion in the debate on
last night and that she's been making in
recent days that she never supported
self-id certainly uh kemi badenash and
officials um
in her department when she was there
had the very strong impression that she
did so it does look
as if she has changed her stance in
order to appeal to tory party members
and if we are actually meant to be
you know ringing the changes from a
prime minister who
flip-flops we know that dominic cummings
calls him the shopping trolley
and who is not always truthful then this
doesn't look like a very good start in
fact it looks slightly continuity boris
johnson so let's see what emerges from
it but there are other assertions that
have emerged in recent days about um her
time as a naval reservist uh apparently
you know people who were who are in the
navy have again suggested that she has
overstated her position there and you
know sort of claimed to have a kind of
military background that her record
simply doesn't justify so none of this
is particularly working in her favor
okay henry
i think this is um always going to be a
problem for penny morton uh is that the
her campaign when it started and it did
have this spectacular launch it was
mostly or at least in part because she
was a relatively unknown figure she had
a few things that took the right boxes
you know she had been in cabinet she is
very she's she's telegenic and but she
was largely a blank slate which means
that conservatives who were tired of
boris johnson and all of the sleeves
involved in the dying days of his
administration could project onto her
whatever they wanted and there was
always a question mark about whether or
not once she came under scrutiny and had
to start having firm policy positions on
things she would be able to keep this up
now the trend the trans issues is
actually one area where up until about a
week ago i would have said it was one of
the few areas where she had staked out a
distinctive and you know perfectly
honorable position whether you agree
with this or not and i think that had
she dug in and defended yes it would
have alienated parts of the of the of
the electorate there's no doubt about
that but i think she might have actually
come off better than what's happened now
we haven't seen these documents but it
certainly seems to be the case that
several people who worked with her in
government including the suella
braverman who was the pregnant minister
who is the reason for the legislation
that they were debating believe that she
staked out a very firm position on this
and is now backpedaling and if you're
already doing that on one issue on one
week of the leadership campaign it's
simply notwithstanding the substance of
the dispute it doesn't show you to be a
break from boris johnson yeah okay well
we'll speak more about the leadership
contest uh in a moment but for now uh
thank you both coming up plenty more
from the papers including this spread in
sunday express trusts i'm the only
candidate who can keep read votes
talking about that and plenty more in a
moment
[Music]
part two of the press preview taking a
look at sunday's front pages with me
christina and henry christine why don't
you start uh things off this uh half
sunday telegraph rishi sunak uh trying
to appeal to those brexiteer mps
yes well
you know there's a tory leadership uh
competition going on when
everybody vows to
destroy red tape um if one single thing
has massively increased a red tape in
this country it is of course brexit
which rishi sunak supported but he has
to appeal and he did you know he has to
appeal he is in a strange position of
having supported brexit but not being
the most popular candidate with the
right of the party so he's now doing
whatever he can to support to
to win the support of the right of the
party and is of course promising um you
know a bonfire of red tape i have to say
that
if he promises it uh i i would have a
lot more faith in his promises than in
any of the other candidates not a
because he's clearly the most serious
candidate and gave by far the best
performance in the debate last night and
is by far the most competent of all of
them but also because he um you know he
he has a good record of getting things
done and i think he is although i think
it's a great shame that he supported
boris johnson and i think he is
absolutely tainted by um the lack of
integrity of boris johnson i think i do
think basically he is a man of integrity
and i think if he says he'll do
something he'll probably try to do it
whether he will get to be leader of the
tory party is another matter because uh
the tory party members seem hell-bent on
getting someone who's more right wing
but you know there may be a bonfire of
red tape but there will certainly not be
a bonfire a brexit red tape okay uh
let's uh we're slightly short time uh
henry so i'm going to move on to the
sunday express their headline uh trust
i'm the only candidate who can keep
redwall votes uh thoughts on this
i mean she keeps saying this i'm not
entirely sure what the evidence base for
it is the tories actually have an
incredibly difficult job to try
at the next election to hold on to that
extraordinarily broad coalition that
boris johnson managed to build they have
to simultaneously try and hold onto the
red wall whilst also shoring up support
in in liberal democrat facing seats in
the south and southwest which have
traditionally been conservative or
slightly better off and have been
alienated by the party in recent years
now
if liz trust has proof actual polling
evidence that she's popular in the red
wall um i'd like to see it but as far as
i can i'm concerned her campaign is
basically cosplaying as margaret
thatcher and i can't think of anything
that's less likely to woo voters who
were attracted to boris johnson's
promise of a new kind of conservatism
right christina
we'll finish with this underdog uh to
tugan hats um he may be the underdog but
he did very well in the tv debate didn't
he
well i don't to be honest i don't think
he did nearly as well as rishi sooner he
look he seems like a nice bloke who has
been untainted by this ghastly corrupt
lying regime and so he was free to do
and say what he liked so when he was
asked whether boris johnson was a liar
as all the candidates were he could just
say yes because or other well he checked
whether he tells the truth he could just
say no and got applause for that you
know it's not like a great uh virtuoso
performance he was just able to speak
the truth in the way that the other
candidates
aren't um i mean
you could see the audience warming to
him i warmed him as i say he seems like
a nice bloke he's not going to be the
next prime minister he doesn't have the
experience to be the next prime minister
so to be honest it's not really relevant
but you know he livens the debates up so
that's nice okay i'm going to ask you
this both very quickly just one answer
each who do you think's going to get to
the final two christina
definitely rishi sunak well not
definitely anything but like rishi sunak
and
i think penny wouldn't but it's either
penny modern or liz truss and i'm not
sure at this point could be liz truss
all right interesting henry
bruce and i think liz trust because i
think that uh she can shore up enough
votes on the right wing of the party
that won't go to penny all right uh very
interesting indeed okay thank you very
much for your thoughts